a developing storm system in the Gulf of
Mexico is likely to become tropical
storm berry by this weekend
meteorologist Megan Glaros of our
Chicago station that's WBBM is tracking
what could potentially turn into a
second named storm in the Atlantic this
year so Megan who needs to be on alert
good morning focusing all our attention
on the Gulf of Mexico right now where
we've got a possible tropical system
brewing you can see where we find the
bright blues down in the Gulf of Mexico
that's where we have a high moisture
content rather disorganized at this
point but moving through time we do
expect to see some consolidation of this
system some strengthening as well we may
be looking at a system that could push
even a surge event onshore parts of
Louisiana including New Orleans all the
way through to Florida as it's gaining
steam maybe making a landfall as a
tropical storm barry would be the name
of this one and that could happen
sometime this weekend very very warm
waters across the Gulf of Mexico right
now when our model guidance is focusing
along the coast of Louisiana but we
could see a landfalling event as far
west as Texas and as far east as Florida
and when that happens we're looking at a
lot of available moisture it's dealing
with all that Gulf moisture and so we
could see upwards of a foot of rain in
spots by Monday Anthony Megan thank you
very much